IMAGINE IF ERIC ADAMS HAD TO
DEAL WITH THAT PROBLEM IN NEW
YORK.
PROBABLY WANT TO BUILD A WALL
TOO.
TEXAS GOVERNOR ABBOTT JOINS ME
NOW.
DO YOU EXPECT THEM TO COME TO
TEXAS TO SEE FOR THEMSELVES
WHAT'S GOING ON?
>> I REALLY WISH THEY WOULD,
BECAUSE PUBLIC OFFICIALS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY, THEY DO NEED TO
REALIZE THE MAGNITUDE OF THE
CHAOS.
THEY'RE UP IN ARMS ABOUT A FEW
THOUSAND PEOPLE COMING INTO
THEIR COMMUNITIES OVER THE PAST
FEW MONTHS.
LISTEN, IN ANY ONE SECTOR IN THE
STATE OF TEXAS WE HAVE MORE THAN
5,000 PEOPLE COMING ACROSS THAT
SECTOR EVERY SINGLE DAY.
LISTEN, WE'RE FULL IN THE STATE
OF TEXAS.
OUR COMMUNITIES ARE OVERRUN.
I STARTED BUSSING PEOPLE TO
WASHINGTON, D.C. WHEN LOCAL
OFFICIALS COULD NOT HANDLE THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT HAD COME
ACROSS THEIR BORDER.
IT'S TIME THESE OFFICIALS IN NEW
YORK -- AND I'M GLAD YOU
MENTIONED "THE NEW YORK
TIMES" -- THEY HAVEN'T REPORTED
ABOUT THIS, ABOUT THE CHAOS AT
THE BORDER.
MAYBE FINALLY "THE NEW YORK
TIMES" WILL ALSO START TALKING
ABOUT THE CHAOS AT THE BORDER
CAUSED BY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION'S CHANGES.
>> Jesse: YOU'RE NOT HANDCUFFING
MIGRANTS AND FORCING THEM
UNWILLINGLY ON TO BUSES AND
TELLING THEM, YOU'RE GOING TO
NEW YORK, YOU'RE GOING TO
WASHINGTON, D.C., AS THEY TRY TO
FIGHT TO GET OFF THE BUS.
THAT'S NOT HAPPENING, RIGHT?
>> EXACTLY.
THEY SIGNED A WAIVER OF
AGREEMENT WHEN THEY BOARD THAT
BUS.
>> Jesse: OKAY, GOOD, BECAUSE
SOME OF THESE MAYORS, BOWSER IN
PARTICULAR, CAN'T IMAGINE WHY
ANYBODY WOULD EVER WANT TO GO TO
D.C.
SHE'S, LIKE, THEY CAN'T WANT
THIS TO BE THEIR FINAL
DESTINATION, WASHINGTON, D.C.,
THE NATION'S CAPITAL.
IT'S AN INDICTMENT ON HER OWN
GOVERNANCE.
DO YOU UNDERSTAND WHEN MAYOR
ADAMS SAYS, WELL, WE HAVE A
HOUSING PROBLEM.
WHY CAN'T THEY FIND HOUSING IN
TEXAS?
WHAT'S YOUR RESPONSE TO THAT?
>> THE CARTEL ARE NOT LOOKING
FOR HOUSING IN TEXAS.
THE CARTELS COMING THROUGH
TEXAS, THEY'RE TRYING TO GET TO
NEW YORK WHERE THEY CAN
DISTRIBUTE WHAT THEY'RE BRINGING
ACROSS THE BORDER.
>> Jesse: EXACTLY.
MAYBE HE SHOULD TAKE YOU UP ON
THE OFFER.
HE COULD TAKE A BUS, JUST LIKE
THE MIGRANTS.
TEXAS GOVERNOR GREG ABBOTT,
THANK YOU.
ONE MORE THING YOU WANTED TO
ADD?
>> WHEN WE DROP THEM OFF,
THEY'RE EMPTY.
THEY CAN GET A